bien d'abord bonjour à tous et merci
d'être l'arbre alors évidemment c'est un
point de presse exceptionnelle vous
voyez qu'il n'ya pas les deux
porte-parole habituel point de presse
que nous avons voulu situer dans le
cadre de la prolongation de l'état
d'urgence qui a été souhaité par le
gouvernement que nous avons voté à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat la
semaine dernière les républicains ont
décidé de mettre en place une mission
des républicains pour la sécurité des
français contre le terrorisme cette
mission est placé sous l'autorité d'eric
woerth qui est notre responsable global
du projet eric woerth qui s'excuse de ne
pouvoir être là ce matin mais c'est donc
sous son autorité
quatre députés nationaux quatre
sénateurs
une députée européenne donc neuf membres
plus eric woerth dit membre de cette
mission
quel est l'objectif de la mission il
s'agit pas contrairement à ce que j'ai
lu ici ou là s'agit en aucun cas de
commencer un à dire que nous faisons des
griffures sur l'unité nationale
il s'agit de dire tout simplement voilà
les parlementaires dans le rôle normal
comme les partis politiques d'opposition
dans le rôle normal contrôler l'action
du gouvernement
nous sommes évidemment favorables à la
prolongation de l'état d'urgence
d'ailleurs pas une voix n'a manqué chez
les républiques à l'assemblée nationale
et au sénat pour voter pour
donc nous sommes favorables à cette
prolongation
nous avons soutenu depuis le mois de
janvier toutes les mesures qui ont été
proposées par le gouvernement que ce
soit la loi sur le renseignement que ce
soit les l'augmentation des crédits
ce soit un certain nombre de
recrutements nous avons toujours voté
favorablement mais nous sommes dans la
situation de dire
les français veulent des garanties sur
leur sécurité leur protection
de fait un certain nombre d'engagements
pris au mois de janvier n'ont pas été
tenues entre janvier et novembre pour
des raisons diverses blocage juridique
blocage financier blocage budgétaire
très bien enfin de fait un certain
nombre de choses n'ont pas été faites et
résultat des courses un jour d'hui nous
disons au gouvernement la sécurité des
français méritent effectivement la
prolongation de l'état d'urgence
nous soutiendrons et nous avons dit au
sénat comme à l'assemblée que nous
soutiennent soutenions l'ensemble des
mesures adoptées
nous demandons on va y revenir parfois
aller un peu plus loin et surtout
l'objectif de cette mission au-delà des
propositions supplémentaires
c'est évidemment de dire pas seulement
des paroles
les français veulent des actes les
français veulent l'unité
les français ne veulent pas que l'on se
fasse ddd guignolade de 2,2 de critiques
pour rien et ils ont raison
la sécurité est la première des libertés
par conséquent il faut là dessus être
entièrement d'accord et naturellement
personne ne conteste comme c'est un
pouvoir régalien c'est d'abord à
l'action du gouvernement que cela va
mais encore faut-il que dans nos rôles
de parlementaires nous puissions
vérifier contrôler l'application
vérifier que tout ce qui est annoncé se
met en place dans quelles conditions
avec quels moyens et c'est l'objet de
cette mission
cette mission elle travaillera de
manière simple d'abord au parlement nous
sommes tous parlementaire par le travail
classique des parlementaires la capacité
d'interpeller le gouvernement par des
questions écrites et avec l'accord de
nos groupes par des questions
d'actualité ici même nous nous réunirons
régulièrement pour faire le point entre
les 10 sur l'application l'évolution de
l'application les moyens mis en oeuvre
pour justement assurer la sécurité des
français et nous ferons régulièrement
des communiqués des 10
pour dire voilà où nous en sommes voilà
ce qui est fait voilà ce qui pourrait
être mieux fait voilà ce qui n'est pas
fait donc en réalité c'est une mission
de contrôle une mission de deux
d'interpellations ça n'est pas je le
redis mise en cause ou une mise en doute
mais nous voulons que la sécurité des
français soit totalement assurée par
l'application réelle et rapide des
mesures qui sont annoncées et de
certaines que nous allons faire en plus
puisque le gouvernement
aussi bien le président de république
que le premier ministre nous ont dit
nous sommes ouverts aux propositions de
l'opposition nous sommes disposés à
discuter à négocier et à voir ce qui
peut être fait en plus
eh bien nous rentrons parfaitement dans
ce cadre alors si vous le voulez bien je
vais demander à guillaume et alain
d'intervenir sur les éléments
sécuritaires au sens classique du terme
puis à rachida et à georges d'intervenir
sur le niveau européen sur la politique
pénale bien merci donc rejet a rappelé
que nous avions aux républicains voter
les textes qui nous ont été proposés ça
a été d'autant plus naturel pour nous au
delà de l'envi que nous avions de
soutenir les pouvoirs publics et ceux
qui les incarnent aujourd'hui qu'au fond
toutes les mesures beaucoup des mesures
qui sont annoncées sont celles que nous
mêmes nous nous réclamions ici aux
républicains depuis un certain nombre un
certain nombre de mois donc il en va de
l'interdiction de retour d'un djihadiste
binational en france nous avions demandé
depuis depuis longtemps la déchéance de
nationalité pour un terroriste
binational d'ailleurs y compris né en
france puisque c'est la proposition qui
nous est qui nous est faite
l'expulsion en urgence des personnes
étrangères qui font l'apologie du
terrorisme également donc autant de
mesures que nous avions
demandez la présomption de légitime
défense pour nos forces de sécurité qui
était aussi une de nos demandes rappelez
vous la journée de travail que nous
avions fait donc sur la sécurité
autant de mesures qui sont annoncées
aujourd'hui et pour lesquels donc nous
allons comme l'a dit roger tout à
l'heure vérifier semaine après semaine
qu'elles vont effectivement ce se mettre
en place et nous reviendrons justement
pour faire le point sur leur efficacité
et éventuellement sur les sujets sur
lesquels nous pourrions aller un petit
peu plus loin je vais passer le micro
peut-être tout de suite à guillaume pour
parler d'autres sujets comme le pnr qui
également est aujourd'hui proposée en
nous qu'on si c'est peut-être plus tôt
rachida qu'il offre à tout à l'heure
mais sur la question des mesures de
sécurité intérieure on voit bien qu'au
fond tout ce qui est annoncé a été
demandée par nous donc nous ce que nous
voulons faire déjà puisque avant de
contrôler l'action du gouvernement ou de
suivre l'action du gouvernement l'idée
c'est de faire un petit inventaire de ce
qui est de ce qui est proposé
cet inventaire en termes de politique
intérieure on voit bien que ça
représente
il faut lactée et s'en réjouir que ça
représente une j'allais dire un virage à
180 degrés dans la politique qui est
annoncée nouvelle politique que
sécuritaire qui est annoncé par le
président de la république et le
gouvernement
notre seule préoccupation vous l'avez
compris c'est l'efficacité
opérationnelle au service de la sécurité
des français
je voudrais revenir très précisément sur
la question extrêmement importante parce
que d'effets immédiats de la
mobilisation opérationnelle des forces
de sécurité intérieure c'est à dire des
forces de la police nationale et de la
gendarmerie nationale premièrement nous
avons demandé par un amendement que j'ai
présenté au nom des républicains
l'assemblée nationale que les
fonctionnaires de la police nationale
soit désormais autorisés à porter leurs
armes en dehors des heures de service
le gouvernement nous entendu sur ce
point puisque un arrêté a été pris
qui permet cela depuis vendredi
deuxièmement nous souhaitons que les
réserves de la police nationale et de la
gendarmerie nationale soit activé dès
maintenant et nous avons à cet égard des
préoccupations car nous avons relevé que
dans le projet de loi de finances pour
actuellement discuté au sénat est votée
en première lecture à l'assemblée
nationale dans le projet de loi de
finances pour 2016
les crédits de la réserve de la police
nationale diminue de 50 % il était de 21
millions d'euros en 2015
ils sont de 14 millions d'euros en 2016
il est donc urgent nous demandons
aujourd'hui solennellement que le
gouvernement par un amendement
augmentent très significativement les
crédits de la réserve de la police
nationale parce qu'on voit bien que la
mobilisation immédiate dans les jours et
les semaines à venir de réservistes de
la police nationale est beaucoup plus
efficace que la non ce qui est en
réalité virtuelle de recrutement différé
de policiers dans les années à venir
à cet égard je veux souligner pour mon
alertait que de 2012 à 2015
contrairement à ce qui a été dit les
effectifs réels de la police et de la
gendarmerie nationale ont diminué 1965
postes de policiers et de gendarmes en
effectifs réels en moins sur les trois
premières années du quinquennat de
françois hollande
voilà une réalité opérationnelle qui
convient de combler par le recours à des
heures supplémentaires et par la
mobilisation je le répète de réservistes
dès maintenant
s'agissant toujours des policiers
nous appelons le gouvernement à nous
saisir au plus vite et nous n'avons pas
encore cela à l'ordre du jour ni de
l'assemblée ni du sénat d'un projet de
loi relatif aux règles d'emploi des
armes par la police nationale
b l'été 2012 nous avons fait une
proposition et j'étais le rapporteur en
décembre 2012 à l'assemblée nationale au
nom de l'ump à l'époque d'une
proposition de loi en ce sens et nous
avons fait cela ensuite à plusieurs
initiatives avec eric ciotti qui est
philippe goujon qui eux aussi avaient
fait des propositions de loi
indépendamment de cela aujourd'hui nous
sommes n'est ce pas à la fin de l'année
2015 nous souhaitons que avant la fin du
mois l'assemblée nationale puisse
adopter le nouveau régime juridique de
l'emploi des armes
cette question a été étudiée réétudier
examiné à de multiples reprises
maintenant il est temps d'agir et
d'adapter juridiquement au plus vite les
règles qui permettront aux policiers de
mieux nous défendre et de mieux se
défendre puisque aussi bien comme vous
le savez les règles d'emploi son père
est identique entre la police et la
gendarmerie en été il faut rapprocher
celles de la police nationale de celle
de la de la gendarmerie nationale
je pourrais évoquer par ailleurs puisque
j'ai le micro la question de la révision
constitutionnelle
nous nous sommes exprimés les uns les
autres à l'assemblée et au sénat jeudi
et vendredi
notre seule préoccupation c'est
l'efficacité
si la révision constitutionnelle est un
exercice d'esthétique juridique qui
consisterait à inscrire les mots état
d'urgence dans la constitution
cela n'aurait aucun effet aucun effet
opérationnel
aucun effet juridique à dire vrai si en
revanche 7 m
lution constitutionnel permettait
l'adoption d'instruments utile à la
protection des français alors nous
l'examinons riom de manière ouverte et
pour le dire de manière plus directe
c'est au gouvernement de nous soumettre
un projet de loi de révision
constitutionnelle puisque il l'annonçait
précis à partir duquel les commissions
des lois des deux assemblées est ici les
républicains pourront examiner
précisément ce qui était ce qui est
proposé
oui je voudrais juste rappeler avant de
donner la parole à rachida qu en matière
de révision constitutionnelle annoncer
quelque chose tous les deux pour avoir
conduit celle de 2008
c'est long c'est très long et
franchement annoncé qu' on va faire une
révision constitutionnelle
non seulement il faut savoir exactement
ce qu'on veut changer dans les articles
concernés mais en plus il faut se dire
que c'est pas ça qui va renforcer la
sécurité des français aujourd'hui et que
la sécurité des français
elle dépendra des applications rapide
immédiate et des moyens mise en
application
la révision constitutionnelle si elle
doit conforter la loi de 55 ou créer une
situation d'urgence aggravée très bien
mais c'est un élément final c'est pas un
élément immédiat l'élément immédiat
c'est naturellement de prendre les
mesures tout de suite rachida justement
pnr contrôle des frontières schengen
là dessus le gouvernement lorsqu'il ya
eu les débats d'ailleurs à l'assemblée
au sénat sur le droit d'asile ou sur
l'immigration
l'actuel gouvernement était très en
retrait par rapport à nos propositions
très en retrait nous refusons le
contrôle des frontières l'on refuse un
certain nombre de contrôles des migrants
refusant de précipiter la mise en place
du pnr à la fois nos responsabilités
européennes et puis responsabilité
globale sur l'ensemble de ces mesures
c'est à toi
sur sur l'aspect de lutte plus
globalement contre le terrorisme après
les attentats du mois de janvier le
parlement européen m'a confié
effectivement un rapport à faire sur la
lutte contre la radicalisation mais
aussi sur la lutte contre le recrutement
de citoyens européens par des
organisations terroristes parce que
pendant longtemps on a considéré que ces
djihadistes étaient des combattants
étrangers ils ne le sont plus parce que
ce sont aujourd'hui des citoyens
européens c'est pour ça que je dis qu'on
a engendré en notre sein aujourd'hui des
monstres et des criminels
il ya beaucoup de mesures qui ont été
adoptées dans ce rapport que j'ai
effectivement remis cet été qui a été
adopté en commission dit libé au
parlement européen le 19 octobre dernier
il sera voté en plénière la semaine
prochaine donc ces mesures étaient
reprenait celle de ma famille politique
mais aussi celle du ppe au niveau du
parlement européen ce que lutter contre
le terrorisme aujourd'hui c'est lutter
au niveau européen
dire que on adapte des mesures
nationales roger en a fait état avec
guillaume et alain mais on ne peut pas
lutter contre le terrorisme
uniquement avec des mesures nationales
mesures européennes obligatoirement mais
aussi mesures internationales puisque
nous avons aussi changé de braquet sur
la politique maintenant étrangères sur
les mesures européennes
c'est vrai que nous ça fait très
longtemps et notamment le groupe ppe et
les républicains que nous demandions ce
fameux pnr le pnrc quoi c'est d'avoir la
liste des passagers qui eux qui prennent
l'avion au niveau de l'europe cirque
europe avec des pays tiers
allers retours que nous ayons la
traçabilité le mouvement de l'ensemble
des passagers et en particulier ceux qui
sont considérés comme fish est signalé
surveiller ou considérés comme dangereux
c'est le cas par exemple avec la
compagne de coulibaly au mois de janvier
où finalement on retrouve que la partie
de madrid en turquie puis en syrie
c'est parce que les services de
renseignement espagnols nous donne
l'information si nous avions eu ce pnr
européen nous aurions pu très rapidement
la localiser savoir à quel moment
notamment lé parti dont nous avons
besoin de ce pnr européen qui nous a été
à chaque fois rejetées en raison des
députés socialistes
français owni parlement européen c'est
une réalité moi j'entends valse qui dit
je suis choqué je comprends pas pourquoi
des députés européens s'opposent au pnr
mais ce sont les siens nous on a
toujours été très favorable ce pnr
européen nous avions déjà eu d'ailleurs
des réunions avec bernard cazeneuve pour
le soutenir dans sa démarche ce qu'il
souhaitait effectivement le pnr
européens et on va plus loin et
d'ailleurs le conseil de vendredi l'a
accepté donc nous on se dit il a fallu
cette tragédie pour que nous puissions
obtenir la mesure supplémentaire pnr
européens union européenne pays tiers
mais il fut il nous faut un pnr intra
européen parce que les terroristes sont
toujours inconnues un coup j'ai un code
pénal d' avance parce que quand ils
savent qu un pnr pays tiers hors union
européenne
ils iront dans le pays où il y en a pas
donc si on a un pénètre à européen on ne
pourra effectivement on pourra essayer
resserrer les mailles du filet ça c'est
la première chose il a été effectivement
adoptés dans le cast dans le cadre du
conseil de vendredi dernier contrôle
systématique nous souhaitions le
contrôle systématique
aujourd'hui il n'est pas systématique de
des passeports aux frontières
extérieures l'union européenne c'est
qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes citoyen
européen
vous brandissez votre placement ils vont
passer on veut un contrôle systématique
des passeports à l'entrée de l'union
européenne nous voulions la gauche était
contre a été décidée au conseil
vendredi dernier il ya un autre sujet ça
on disait oui mais le mandat d'arrêt est
ce que les mandats d'arrêt il ya
peut-être une faille là dessus il faut
savoir qu'on a un fichier qui s'appelle
le fichier et cs dans le cadre du code
schengen series east non et c'est pas
ici et dire que les services de
renseignement fin les services de police
et du 6e et interpol abonde cette base
de données avec eux ça peut être du
renseignement des mandats d'amener des
mandats de recherche beau mandat d'arrêt
est souvent on se rend compte que cette
base de données est mal renseigné ou pas
renseigné sur ce que vous pouvez avoir
quelqu'un qui passe à l'as et donc il
faudra renforcer et obligé beaucoup plus
à remplir ses bases de données pour
lutter en tout cas pouvoir interpeller
aux frontières des individus recherchés
ou contre lesquels il ya un mandat
d'arrêt donc ce qui a été décidé
vendredi faut savoir que ça a été décidé
mais c'est pas du tout mis en oeuvre
soit on a l'impression que tout ça est
humiliante il faut non seulement
l'accord du conseil
l'accord de la commission puis un vote
au parlement ça va prendre encore
plusieurs mois il faut savoir que la
commission européenne est assez
réticente sur la réforme du code
schengen donc on est donc c'est plutôt
ses vingt cinq ans nous sommes vigilants
parce que les annonces faites par valls
c'est très bien mais encore faut-il que
ce soit mise en oeuvre au niveau
européen sinon ça n'a aucun intérêt et
d'une façon ça sera pas mis en oeuvre
et ça n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui les seules mesures qui sont
mises en oeuvre on est dans le cadre de
l'état d'urgence ya aucune mesure
nouvelle tout ce qui est fait c'est état
d'urgence
certes effectivement perquisition
assignation serre que c'est si l'état
d'urgence s'arrête toutes ces mesures
s'arrête donc on revient comme avant
donc il faut aussi avoir ça en tête doc
/ sur ces mesures-là donc dans le
rapport que j'ai remis des
radicalisations pour l'essentiel
radicalisation 90% c'est le net et les
prisons les mosquées c'est subsidiaire
mais ça existe quand même parce qu'on a
un sujet des financements donc
radicalisation sur le net on l'a fait
adopter dans le cas de la commission le
responsable pénal des géants d'internet
on souhaite en plénière faire adopter
des sanctions pénales à l'encontre des
géants d'internet sur les prisons de
pouvoir avoir des mises à l'écart de
détenus radicaliser ou en processus de
radicalisation comme ça se passe à
fresnes d'ailleurs qui peut marcher
parce qu'on peut avoir effectivement
décortiqué à voir là le processus de
radicalisation et donc nous ça nous
intéresse savoir comment ce radicalisme
notamment en prison ça nous permet
d'avoir de l'information notamment pour
les recruteurs parce que c'est une
réalité il ya des détenus en prison des
recruteurs qui peuvent donner des
instructions à l'extérieur c'est aussi
une réalité et on peut avoir de
l'information pour lutter contre ces
réseaux
donc ça c'est extrêmement important
l'annnonce du sang de déradicalisation
annoncé par valls nous on souhaite
effectivement qu'il y ait les centres de
déradicalisation mais ce qui est annoncé
par valdes est-ce que c'est sur le
volontariat ou est-ce que si sur une
injonction volontariat ça marchera pas à
mon sens et donc les centres de
déradicalisation tel qu'il en existe pas
supposé exister aujourd'hui ça n'est pas
les centres de déradicalisation que nous
souhaitons parce que ce modèle est à
construire
comme on l'a fait par exemple pour les
phénomènes sectaires mais aussi
lorsqu'on crée la rétention de sûreté
qu'on a fait adopter
sous sous notre mandature la rétention
de sûreté
c'est de lutter contre les violeurs en
syrie tueur en série et donc on a mis
ycompris en prison pour pouvoir
prononcer cette rétention de sûreté des
commissions pluridisciplinaires avec des
professionnels qui évalue notamment la
dangerosité donc tout ce modèle de sang
de déradicalisation est à construire
ça n'existe pas en l'état actuel des
choses l'angleterre l'allemagne par
exemple sont très avancées sur ces
sujets nous nous sommes très en retard
sur la déradicalisation pour ne pas dire
qu'on est au point mort donc il ya
beaucoup de mesures qu'on doit
effectivement avoir en france il ya un
sujet qui peut faire débat c'est la
financier parce que lutter contre le
terrorisme c'est aussi lutter contre son
financement
et aujourd'hui on a un vrai sujet la
belgique par exemple un vrai sur son
sujet à l'origine notamment pour les
mosquées et les imams parce qu'ils
étaient payés pour l'essentiel par des
pays étrangers notamment des pays du
golfe donc on a un sujet il faudra
effectivement qu'on prenne à bras le
corps le sujet du financement de
structures d'associations d'individus
ont la dp des imams qui sont payés par
des pays étrangers
est ce qu'on doit continuer l'accepter
donc tous ces sujets là on l'a fait
adopter dans le cadre de ce rapport on
souhaite soit en plénière et que ce soit
ensuite mises en oeuvre notamment sur le
territoire national très bien aimé dans
l'état d'urgence georges
il ya un certain nombre de mesures qui
sont prises en matière de sécurité que
nous avons soutenu que nous avons
souvent proposent avant enfin toutes ces
mesures de sécurité ne peuvent être
appliquée que si la politique pénale
suis et si réellement il ya la
conjonction sécurité justice qui soit un
peu plus opérationnel que ce qu'on
entend parler syndicat de commissaires
de police ou par des manifestations de
policiers
alors est-ce qu'en la matière les
mesures prises par le gouvernement
récemment vont dans le bon sens qu'est
ce qu'on peut proposer de plus
et qu'est ce que nous allons nous-mêmes
et demande est contrôlée merci la juste
ce en ce moment évidemment observe avec
particulière vigilance qui est en train
de se passer puisque c'est en dehors
d'elles sont des pressions
administratives prises dans le cadre de
la procédure d'urgence que nous
soutenons cela a été rappelé mais mesure
d'urgence n'a qu'un temps va falloir
ensuite revenir au droit commun et le
droit commun que je sache aujourd'hui
nous sommes toujours sous l' empire de
la politique pénale de madame taubira
qui à notre sens est évidemment
absolument insuffisante pour lutter
contre ces nouvelles menaces le
président la république lors du congrès
à versailles a annoncé modifications ou
des réformes de procédure pénale sans
donner le moindre contenu et pour la
première fois à ma connaissance le
président de la république a fait le
lien entre les criminels de droit commun
qui bascule dans la radicalisation et
qui basculent certains dans le
terrorisme puisque d'autres comme ana
bauer ont appelé les gangs ce terrorisme
contre cela nous allons être
particulièrement vigilant à tous les
niveaux en commission des lois lors des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
auprès du garde des sceaux notamment
pour savoir quelles sont les mesures
effectives qui vont être prises au
niveau de la procédure pénale
je voudrais insister surtout sur le fait
que malgré les annonces d'augmentation
des moyens qui seront attribués à la
justice on a parlé de 2000 avec
l'administration pénitentiaire les juges
d'un petit terroriste le disent c'est le
cas nous l'avons entendu dans la
commission d' enquête présidée par
ciotti sur la science des filières
jihadistes que ils n'ont pas les moyens
d'exercer l'envers lors enquête
notamment au niveau des services
spécialisés des enquêteurs d'après
judiciaire
donc nous attendons de voir quels seront
les moyens supplémentaires
ils ne sont très vigilant là dessus
qu'ils seront attribués à aux enquêtes
et à la justice donc ceci pour vous dire
que cette conversion sécuritaire de la
gauche nous en prenons acte
mais nous restons extrêmement vigilants
il suffirait par exemple je passe je
parle sous le contrôle un ancien garde
des sceaux rachida dati
il suffirait que madame taubira prennent
aujourd'hui même y a pas besoin de
réformes constitutionnelles une
circulaire une circulaire adressée à
l'ensemble des parquets déjà pour
arrêter les réductions de peines
automatiques et les examens automatique
de libération conditionnelle
y compris pour les récidivistes je
rappelle que c'est sa circulaire du 9
janvier pendant les attentats parisien
de l'hyper cacher qui rappelait aux
procureurs d'aligner des récidivistes
sur les primo délinquants
donc nous attendons ça serait peut-être
un signe
véritable de conversion sécuritaire en
ce moment que le garde des sceaux a
adressé une circulaire aux parquets pour
leur demander de réexaminer la procédure
de réductions de peines automatiques de
permissions de sortir et de liebherr et
d'examen des automatique des libérations
conditionnelles
voilà pour ce qui concerne évidemment la
rétention de sûreté
elle s'impose la rétention de sûreté qui
avait été adoptée sous le précédent
quinquennat effectivement elle
s'applique aujourd'hui uniquement pour
les criminels récidivistes criminels
sexuels et autres il faut c'est la
logique c'est le bon sens les tendres
aussi à tous ceux qui ont été condamnés
pour des faits liés au terrorisme et qui
ne doivent pas se retrouver dans la
nature
il faut créer ces centres de sûreté ces
places pour les terroristes voilà ce que
je souhaitais dire donc pour l'instant
des annonces mais nous attendons une
présomption de bonne foi du gouvernement
mais nous attendons des actes concrets
et des réformes concrètes
pour la mise en oeuvre d'une nouvelle
politique pénale oui juste un petit
complément par rapport à ce que vient de
dire des georges fenech sûr sur cette
politique pénale
je crois qu'il n'y a pas eu de nouvelle
circulaire effectivement de politique
pénale prises par madame la garde des
sceaux depuis depuis la sphère de
charlie hebdo le drame de charlie hebdo
et c'est évidemment un sujet un sujet
important parce que depuis depuis le
drame de charlie on aurait pu regarder
un certain nombre de de faire
différemment et peut-être s'interroger
sur la sur la qualification des faits
que l'on retient je pense par exemple
aux jihadistes de retour de retour de
syrie la question de la qualification
pénale que l'on retient pour les faits
n'est évidemment pas neutre
la loi terrorisme de novembre 2014 à
créer de nouvelles infractions elle a
permis d'élargir le spectre des
infractions des incriminations possible
mais ne doit pas nous faire renoncer
pour autant à un usage des
incriminations qui sont dans le code
pénal et qui sont les cas échéant plus
dur et plus adapté aux personnes en
cause la question de la politique pénale
elle se pose aussi de manière immédiate
georges fenech et guillaume larrivé l'on
dit aujourd'hui il ya une grande
efficacité instantanée dans l'état
d'urgence parce que l'état d'urgence
permet aux forces de l'ordre d'agir
directement si je puis dire à la demande
du ministre de l'intérieur
mais se pose en ce moment même la
qualification pénale des faits qui va
être retenue derrière dire des individus
chez qui on trouve des armes
qu'est-ce qui se passe voilà donc cette
question de l'appétit pénale elle aussi
elle est aussi très immédiate
c'est évidemment une condition de
l'efficacité de l'action du gouvernement
le gouvernement doit marcher sur ses
deux jambes et nous serons donc
évidemment très vigilants à ce qu'il se
passe quelque chose sur le plan de la
politique pénale
voilà vous voyez que vous
demain vous voyez que l'état d'esprit
n'est pas du tout un état d'esprit ni
agressif ni de remise en cause
ce que nous disons simplement c'est que
nous allons jouer le rôle de
parlementaire d'opposants mais des
opposants constructifs ya pas de notre
part volonté d'utiliser ou d'avoir une
quelconque manoeuvre
c'est simplement que nous ne voulons pas
que ce qui est annoncé pour la sécurité
des français reste un grand pas thouars
nous ne voulons pas avoir les mauvaises
surprises que nous avons eues depuis le
mois de janvier et nous souhaitons que
les engagements pris soient respectés
nous ferons nous allons commencer à
faire des propositions le ministère de
l'intérieur le ministère de la justice
reprendront ne reprendront pas sûrs at
débat et dialogue
nous sommes dans le débat dans le débat
constructif positif pour une meilleure
sécurité rapide des français voilà les
français ont besoin d'être rassurés et
besoin les français ont besoin de se
dire que leur classe politique n'est pas
en train de s'écharper sur ces mesures
là et c'est bien l'état d'esprit dans
lequel moussa